in your experience what are some of the
biggest time wasters on set that could
really be eliminated I think that at the
end of the day the biggest way to waste
time on a film set is not to communicate
your vision and communicating your
vision is something that has to be
executed across all levels of production
from your above-the-line crew to the
below-the-line crew to everyone from the
production assistant to the caterer
everyone needs to understand what your
goals are as a filmmaker because if you
don't explain that clearly to everyone
if everyone doesn't realize what
direction they're paddling the boat in
you're gonna have a lot of questions
you're gonna have a lot of stops and
pauses throughout production because one
arm doesn't know what the other arm is
doing it's very very important for you
as a director to really clarify that to
everyone and make sure that everyone
understands what that thing is and while
you're doing it communicating in a way
that's professional and polite I've seen
other directors that I think treat their
crews in ways that are not acceptable
you've got to be polite I think it's
very important to treat everyone with
respect all the way from the bottom to
the top you treat your producer just as
well as you treat the PA because when
you do that you're not only creating a
good work environment for your team but
you're also making sure that everyone
feels respected and wanted so for me
it's those two things
you